[Music]
all right so after years of serious
misconduct former CIA chief and Obama
sycophant John Brennan can kiss his
security clearance bye-bye
today President Trump strip Brennan's
special government access now Sarah
Sanders announced this decision earlier
today take a look I've decided to revoke
the security clearance of John Brennan
former director of the Central
Intelligence Agency
at this point in my administration any
benefits that senior officials might
glean from consultations with mr.
Brennan are now outweighed by the risks
posed by his erratic conduct and
behavior second that conduct and
behavior has tested and far exceeded the
limits of any professional courtesy that
may have been due to him mr. Brennan has
a history that caused into question his
objectivity and credibility I'm
evaluating action with respect to the
following individuals James clapper
James Comey Michael Hayden Sally Yates
Susan Rice Andrew McCabe Peter struck
Lisa Paige and Bruce or security
clearances for those who still have them
may be revoked and those who have
already lost their security clearance
may not be able to have it reinstated it
is about time for months right here on
this program we have been calling out
Brennan over a serious and blatant abuse
of power for example during his time as
Obama CIA director John Brennan was
responsible for the proliferation of
Christopher Steele's dirty dossier in an
effort to take down then candidate
Donald Trump and legitimize salacious
unverified claims Russian lies found in
that dossier Brennan actually leaked its
contents to then Senator Harry Reid who
then subsequently alerted the public in
an open letter to James Comey he pushed
Hillary Clinton's Russian lives to
purposely deceive and lie to you the
American people why so he could sway an
election and despite all of this
remember Brennan told Congress well the
CIA did not make use of the dirty
dossier that was a flat-out lie and that
my friends is a gross abuse of power
Brennan literally tried to use your
federal government to weaponize the
Clinton camp
pains phony Russian opposition research
against Donald Trump
it's beyond disgusting and by the way
he's a walking talking representative of
why the American people do not have
faith and trust in their government and
by the way and speaking of talking after
stepping down as CIA director John
Brennan well he's done a lot of it in
fact he took all his hatred of Donald
Trump from the highest levels of the CIA
abusing his power to his new job
he's now paid by a so-called news agency
conspiracy TV MSNBC so-called news
channel he continues to peddle all this
propaganda and misinformation and
disinformation how fitting take a look
at the conduct from a former so-called
nonpartisan CIA director who once had
his fingers on every American secret we
have watch this
Donald Trump has badly sullied the
reputation of the office of the
presidency with his invective with his
constant disregard I think for human
decency he is I think the most divisive
president we've ever had in the Oval
Office he is feeding and fueling hatred
and animosity and misunderstandings
among Americans I think there's a big
question first of all in terms of those
who are on mr. Trump's national security
team whether they can continue to serve
in good conscience an individual who
basically betrayed his nation what mr.
Trump did yesterday was to betray the
women men of the FBI the CIA NSA and
others and to betray the American public
and that's why I used the term that this
is nothing short of treasonous I think
he's afraid of the President of Russia
why well no I think one could speculate
as to why that the Russians may have
something on him personally that they
could always roll out and make his life
more difficult mr. Trump continues to
have his ignorant of the facts of
willful disregard of them again just to
follow through on these campaign
promises that really were
very flawed I and so many other former
national officials are speaking out
because of the abnormal and aberrant
behavior of mr. Trump this is a very
large and painful national kidney stone
the relief we feel afterward is going to
be just delivered now for anybody that
thinks that that man that Trump hating
partisan MSNBC hack should have a
security clearance let me make this very
simple and easy to understand and by the
way I'll read to you from the official
CIA rules and by the way all of you
biased acts in the media you need to do
your jobs you need to tell your
audiences the truth what the rules of
the CIA are quote in the case of former
directors the agency holds their
security clearance and renews it every
five years for the rest of their lives
however that requires former CIA
directors to behave like current CIA
employees so is what you saw is that you
know a man demeaning a sitting president
of the United States on a daily basis on
national TV is that acceptable behavior
for a sitting member of the CIA of
course not but the always indignant John
Brennan he's lashing out yet again today
writing on Twitter quote this action is
part of a broader effort by mr. Trump to
suppress freedom of speech and punish
critics it should gravely worry all
Americans including intelligence
professionals about the cost of speaking
out my principles are worth far more
than clearances I will not relent mr.
Brennan then followed that up with a
more vitriolic appearance on ya
conspiracy TV and BC take a look I do
believe that mr. Trump decided to take
this action as he's done with others to
try to intimidate and suppress any
criticism of him or his administration
and revoking my security clearances is
his way of trying to get back at me I've
seen this type of behavior and actions
on the part of foreign tyrants and
despots and autocrats for many many
years during my
CIA and a security career I never ever
thought that I would see it here in the
United States and so I I do believe that
all Americans really need to take the
stock of what is happening right now in
our governments I love getting lectured
from former communists this country is a
better place tonight without that man
having his fingers on America's most
sensitive secrets how a former communist
ever became Barack Obama's CIA director
is another insane part of all this now
meanwhile lacera Sanders announced nine
other current or former officials
security clearances are also under
review including the liar the leaker
that is known as James clapper that
would include James Comey Andrew McCabe
Susan Rice Peter struck Bruce or and
others my advice clean it up now
get rid of all these clearances we could
easily make the case all night tonight
each of these disgrace or fired
officials should lose their clearances
permanently but we'd have to take all
night but we do once again have other
breaking news to talk about about one of
the people on that list according to an
exclusive report from Sarah Carter we
now have smoking gun evidence of the
very special relationship between
demoted DOJ official Bruce or and ex
foreign spy Christopher Steele who put
that phony dossier together Carter has
uncovered yet another series of texts
tonight between or and steel in one text
look at this Christopher steel
expressing concern about James commis
2017 congressional testimony writing two
days before that testimony hi just
wondering if you had any news obviously
we're a bit apprehensive given the
scheduled appearance at Congress on
Monday hoping that important firewalls
will hold many thanks or rights back
sorry no new news
I believe my earlier information is
still accurate I'll let you know
immediately if there's any change
sounds like the firewalls in place what
are these firewalls
what did Christopher steel have to hide
and what was Bruce or trying to cover up
and why was Monday so important as we
said though that's the day that James
was set to testify before Congress and
steel was afraid let's see we know of
the Senate Intel committee and their
scrutiny he was afraid of media scrutiny
he wanted a firewall to hold firewalls
plural Bruce or Steele had at least we
now know 70 contacts and meanwhile
Steele was just desperate to get his
dossier in the hands of Robert Muller
and under oath and Great Britain we know
that he couldn't even stand by his own
fake claims in his Clinton bought and
paid for dossier he said it's just raw
intelligence I don't know if it's true
now why is or still working at the DOJ
why his wife worked for fusion GPS what
was her role remember we just discovered
that they had another client beside
Clinton we just learned a Kremlin @id
lawyer and Russian oligarch so fusion
GPS is being paid by them and the
Clintons and what about Glenn Simpson
from fusion GPS meeting with that
Kremlin lawyer both before and after the
now infamous 2016 Trump Tower meeting
that doesn't sound fishy to you mark it
down on your calendar these questions
must be posed to Bruce or when he
testifies before Congress on August the
28th by the way why aren't those
hearings public we reached out to or for
comment
shockingly didn't receive a reply Sarah
Carter will have more details in the her
report she'll join us in a few minutes
but first we do have an update on the
media's trial of the century after just
12 days closing arguments on both sides
have now come to an end palmat affords
defense is clearly relying on the
terrible credibility of the prosecution
star witness and that's mana forts
former business partner Rick gates
despite him admitting to numerous
felonies team Muller provided gates with
a get-out-of-jail-free card in exchange
for his testimony it's like the case of
remember Sammy the bull Gravano the
gangster who killed up to 19 people and
by the way it's so many other seedy
individuals that our justice system
frequently offers up sentencing
get-out-of-jail-free cards prosecutorial
bribes if you will in exchange for
testimony it's a serious problem
frequently resulting in less than
trustworthy testimony but in the case of
man afford well we should all be
prepared frankly for a guilty verdict
and I'll tell you why
ninety-five percent of federal cases end
up that way and while the media they'll
cheer in unison if Paul Manafort is
found guilty you must remember this this
case of Muller had nothing zero to do
with Russia zero to do with collusion
nothing to do with mana forts work on
the campaign and zero to do with Donald
Trump why are we even here we'll have
more on this throughout the show but now
we turn to the midterm elections which
are only 83 days away and as we
predicted well the language of the left
is getting downright disgusting as it
does every two to four years in
Tennessee Democrat Steve Cohen urged
congresswoman Marsha Blackburn who's
running for the Senate to jump off a
bridge by the way they go high we owe
something like that take a look
cuz Marsha Blackburn if he says jump off
the Harahan bridge children walk under a
bridge I wish she'd say
and if you really want to know how
pathetic the Democratic Party is well
just look at New York it's governor
Democratic Governor Andrew Cuomo
announcing his brand new campaign slogan
I'm not making it up you have to see it
to believe it
take a look we're not gonna make America
great again it was never that great we
have not reached greatness we will reach
greatness when every American is fully
engaged America has never been great
okay test at home Namie one country in
the history of mankind that has
accumulated more power and abused at
less than the United States that has
accumulated more power and used it to
advance the human condition around the
world more than the United States of
America it doesn't exist no we're not
perfect this is the same America that
beat back fascism and communism and
Nazism and Imperial Japan and it stood
for human rights and dignity all around
the world at great cost to this country
now of course what segments on America's
Left would be complete without an over
threat to the President of the United
States take a look this poster from the
band Pearl Jam showing what appears to
be the skeletal remains of a dead
president Trump outside a burning White
House while Pearl Jam apparently wants
the president to go down in flames
most Democrats they'll just settle for
impeachment it is the cornerstone of
what is their political strategy for 83
days should they win in November and no
one has been more upfront about this
plan than the de facto leader of the
Democratic Party Maxine Waters let's
take a look your birthday is on
Wednesday so free happy birthday but on
Wednesday if you could be granted one
birthday wish what would that be I guess
now my biggest birthday wish would be
that we're able to get a leader of this
country who represents us I would wish
that we could remove him from office and
go about getting the
the president that we could all be proud
of and if he's not impeached if he
cannot be impeached 2020 it's coming up
and I believe that American people are
going to do the right thing for our
country stand up for what is right and
get rid of this man who is embarrassing
us all well today Maxine Waters birthday
wish it didn't come true but President
Trump did out of her 80th birthday on
Twitter ero quote happy birthday to the
leader of the Democratic Party Maxine
Waters
on this program we'd also like to wish
congresswoman waters a very happy
birthday and to celebrate while we put
together a montage of the very best of
the leader of the Democratic Party that
would like to take power in 83 days take
a look the Senate Intel committee with
the house in no time at a time tisha
airy I'm in my time okay mr. secretary
they the time belongs to the gentlelady
from California perhaps mr. Chairman I
don't understand the rules because I
thought I was allowed to answer
questions reclaiming my time would you
please explain the rules and do not take
that away from my time with this kind of
inspiration I will go and take Trump out
tonight and I will fight every day until
he is impeached this is a bunch of
scumbags that's what they are those are
very strong words guys around making
money the fact that he is wrapping his
arms around Putin while Putin is
continuing to advance into Korea now
from all of us who support the president
and his agenda keep it up
congresswoman Maxine Waters the most
honest voice in the Democratic Party